احمد داود 25 سؤال لازم تجاوب عليهم بسرعه
من غير تفكير ايش الدور اللي من بعده
الناس بدات تعرفك في الشارع
هل صحيح انك بتخاف من افلام الرعب طب اعمل
لنا فيلم رعب ليه هو يعني اثاره وتشويق
شويه وبيخض كده كم خضه وانا كنت بتخض زي
الناس يعني بصوت حلو هل فائدتك دراسه
الهندسه في التمثيل كيف هي بتفيد اي شغل
في اي حته بتخليك تبصي على الحاجات من فوق
مش جواها يعني ترتبي حياتك بشكل افضل
بتشوفي المشكله بشكل احسن اديتك السينس
بتاع المهندس ده حلو هل احمد داوود نجم صف
اول
بقيه الحمد لله
يوم 13 في بطوله مطلقه معك نجوم تانيين
اكيد لكنه فيلم لاحمد داوود هل
تاخر خالص كان في اول حاجه خالص على عشرين
عشره كان في ولد وبنت بس انا ما كانش ينفع
اصدقها وقتها وبعدين كان في
1920 وده ثالث حاجه يوم 13 انت للرياضه
اللي بتعتبر خطيره اللي هي الكايت سورفنج
اللي بتعمل في نفسك كذا لا مش خطره خالص
هي خطره بس وانت تتعلميها لكن بعد كده دي
كومبو كده بس لما انت كده فوق طالع
ده
ايوه طبعا بس انا
واحده كده ويهرب بص كده على الميه وربنا
بيستر وبعدين في الاخر في الميه مش بتوع
الارض فانا يعني
اكتر منه كمان رياضي يعني هو كده كده
رياضه بيشد الجسم بس كمان انت بتمشي على
خشبه متر في البحر لوحدك شمس جبل ما فيش
حد خالص ما فيش صوت موتور
فبتخرجي حابه كل الناس يعني
[ضحك]
بعد شويه شغل كده ثاني ببقى محتاج زي
المدمن كده اروح اعمل قائد ايش السر اللي
مخليك فنان بعيد عن الشائعات يعني ما
بنسمع عنك شائعات تقريبا ابدا اه والله
الحمد لله بس في مره واحده بس اشعه طلعت
كده برده كانت لها علاقه بقى يمكن قالوا
ان انا عايش في الجونه ههه فانا لا انا لا
لا الحمد لله
طيب كويس بالعربي نجح كم من عشره لو
قارناه بالسدس الاجنبي لا يعني في مصر
والحمد لله ونجح كتير قوي نجح كبير قوي بس
كم من عشره بالظبط بالنسبه لصوص الاجنبي
في مصر
لا بالصوت انت انت شايف العربي وانت شايف
انت مثلت في العربي
مش كتير شفت كم حلقه بس كده وبعدين ما
خليت يعني جوه دماغي وانا بعمل سوتس
بالعربي ما اهتمتش بالاجنبي خالص وحبيت ان
انا اخلق شخصيه جديده خالص بتاعتنا يعني
فما تحس انك تقدر تعمل مقارنه
ايش احلى شيء علا كل حاجه شيء واحد بس
لازم كده اساسا
اقرب ادوارك لقلبك
ممكن اقول لك كذا واحد ولا واحد بس يعني
يفضل واحد اتنين عشان دي اول حاجه في
الدنيا سجن الناس اغير حياتي 120 يوم 13
ههه يلا ولاد رزق وهيبته
طيب البسك
ويت
مشهد لك لما بتشوفه بتقول برافو معلم يا
احمد
مش عارف والله بس لا ما قلتش كده ولا حاجه
بس في حاجات يعني لما الناس بتقول كده
بتبسط اكتر بس انا انا اقول على كده لا مش
فاكر المشهد احد قال لك عليه كده
وفي هذا المساءات كتير اهو ده اللي صار في
مشاهد كتير
ولاد رزق يعني الحمد لله حظي حلو عندي
مشاريع كبيره يعني بيبقى فيها مشاهد صعبه
والحمد لله ربنا بيوفقني فيها طيب صفه صفه
فيك انت نفسك اولادك ادم وجميله ما
يورثوها ابدا
او التوتر يعني اول ما بيحصل حاجه
بتلاقيني كده يبقى نار ولازم امسك نفسي
فبحاول اشتغل عليها يعني اغرب سؤالا سالته
في مجامله
اغرب سؤال لا مش فاكر بصراحه
لو سالنا علا ايش احسن شيء فيك تتوقع ايش
تقول
ريحته حلوه ههه لا هي قالت كده مره يعني
مستعجبتني
لا معرفش هتقول ايه دي حاجه عشان يعني
فقلت اقولها لكن ايه انا يعني كبني ادم
يعني
تسالوها بقى لما تيجي ان شاء الله ان شاء
الله بتحب تتقاعد
بعد مخلص كل حاجه في الجونه وساعتها بقى
يقولوا ان انا عايش في الجونه
وخلاص يعني اروح البحر اتمشى اخد القائد
بتاعتي العب شويه لان انا دلوقتي لما بشوف
ناس كبار في السن بيعملوها ببقى عايز اقول
له الله يعني مش عايز مساعده يا حاج
هل فعلا كنت بطل مصر في الكونغ فو اه
سنتين طب يعني هيكون عيب لو قلت لك مبين
عليك ما هي ما هي مش مكنتش انا بكسب اسمها
ايه
بالقوه قد ما كنت بكسب بالمخ يعني كنت اكس
ايوه طبعا ما هو انت في الاخر بتلعبي نفس
الميزان بتاعك يعني انا لو جسم صغير بلاقي
واحد برده جسمي صغير
مش للمطلق يعني انا في الميزاني بس فكنت
بكسب بالمخ اكتر يعني كنت بستنى واكسب بس
كده نشاط كنت
اكبر منك مش ضروري هتفوز يعني
بس لو في سني كده او في وزني ممكن يعني اه
ان شاء الله نتفاهم يعني طيب اعطيني اسم
واحد لفنان من الجيل الحالي انت بتعتبر
نفسك من الفانز
اوكي سر الزواج الناجح
التنازل
والتفاهم شفت انا قلت ايه الاول التنازل
عشان انت لازم تيجي على نفسك شويه في
حاجات وفي نفس الوقت لازم تبقى متفاهمها
من الناحيه التانيه حاجات ايه ده انا بقول
كلام عميق والله
ممتاز ايش كان شعورك لما انجريت ما نشات
ايرادات فيلم يوم 13 تتخطى ايرادات فيلم
محمد رمضان
انبسطت ان هو اول فيلم بغض النظر عن
الافلام التانيه يعني اتبسطت ان هو من
اليوم السادس لحد النهارده هو اكثر فيلم
بيجيب ايرادات في السينما دي حاجه بتفرح
قوي لان دي ما فيهاش ما فيهاش اسمها ايه
يعني كلام هي بتبقى ارقام فدي حاجه بتفرح
بجد واكثر حاجه بتسعدني اكتشفتها في
الدنيا انك تعمل فيلم في السينما ويجيب
ايرادات يعني انا فاكر كمان وقت 122 لما
كنت رحت اول يوم السينما بالصدفه وشفت
السينما كلها مليانه الناس بداوا يوروني
قاعه في الثانيه في الثالثه لا احساس عمري
ما انساه اكثر حاجه بتفرح في الدنيا الحمد
لله ما بتحبه حتى لو نجح والناس حبته
انا كنت شويه كاره جراند اوتيل وقتها عشان
هو يعني خبطني شويه كنت لسه يعني اثر عليا
شويه فكنت كارهه ليه ياثر عشان هو كان وحش
قوي يعني حتى انا فاكر
وحش قوي وكنت عملتها كمان بعد سجن النساء
فكنت حسيت ان انا بقيت وحش حسيت ان وحش
كده فحتى بعدها اخدت واقفه كده وقلت انا
مش عايز اعمل ادوار كده تاني عايز اعمل
حاجه
يعني
وفعلا عملت ساعتها هذا المساء ما كانش فيه
اي كده طيب سرحت لانك بتحب السينما اكثر
من الدراما ليش والله مش عارف ليه بس لما
جيت انا نفسي بحب الافلام اكتر لما بقعد
في البيت بتفرج افلام اكتر لما بخرج بروح
السينما اكتر بحس ان هما الدوس بتاعي في
الفرجه وفي التمثيل اه اكثر ادوار علا
اللي بتحبها
كان والله لسه مفيش في حاجات كثيره ما
كانتش متصوره كنت كنا بنعمل مع بعض
بتعمل الحاجات خطيره يعني ما افتكرش ان
لسه في دور طلع امكانيات عقلك ممثله لحد
النهارده بس طبعا في السلم انا بحبه جدا
جدا جدا يعني عندها حركه بعينيها كده كانت
بتعملها يعني
لذيذه بس امكانياتك ممثله لسه
شخصين مشهورين ما بتعرفهم شخصيا ونفسك
تعزمهم على العشاء عايشين او ميتين
المصريين ولا اي احد حتى لو اجنبي ماشي
اول حاجه هقول لك دانيال ديليوس تخير
ممتاز والثاني حاجه ليوناردو دي كابري
بحبه دي خيارات ثقيله يعني لازم تعزمني
على العشره
عشان نتكلم مع بعض
شويه بس احب برضه اتعشى كريم عبد العزيز
شخصيه تانيه ممكن اقول منى زكي اعرفهم بس
يعني احب اتعشى معاهم لا خيارات برضو
ممتازه طيب لو عرض عليك الان فيلم بطوله
ثنائيه وطلب منك انك تختار البطل او
البطله اللي جنبك مين تختار لا بصراحه
بتوتر قوي من السؤال ده
عمري يعني حتى لو جاتلي بحس ان حاجه في
حاجه غلط في المعادله دايما دي حاجات
المخرج ممكن اقول رايي رايك بس انا بحس
انه لا طبعا ناس كتير ناس كتيره جدا كل
اللي معاهم لسه نفسي اشتغل معاهم حتى لو
انت بتسمعي انهو كلام وحش قوي حتى لو هم
مش هيبقى زي ما انت في خيالك بس ايه
الفكره ان ده اللي بيعمل اختلاف انك انت
تروح لحتى انت مش مطمن لها او ما تعرفهاش
مين مين مثلا مين كبار ما اشتغلتش عمري مع
كريم عبد العزيز احب جدا اوكي انت اهلاوي
اهلاوي اه بس مش متعصب خالص الاهلاويه
بيقولوا عليا انت مش اهلاوي مش مشكله
سؤالنا ايش احنا شايف الزمالك كفاحه
[ضحك]
يا رب ما يزعلوش
ههه شكرا جدا شكرا جدا
والله لذيذه جدا